[Música]
boa noite
o meu nome é filipe barros eu sou se ou
da sigla web e sou surdo
eu sou surdo mas eu nasci ouvindo e aos
dois anos de idade eu tive meningite e
perdi audição
eu estudo aqui na puc sistema de
informação e eu vim aqui hoje pra contar
um pouco pra vocês a minha mensagem de
superação e como os as pessoas que ouvem
os surdos podem ser iguais
bem eu peço desculpas a vocês para fazer
um parêntese aqui que eu sou casado com
uma surda e ela é muito linda
é durante uma madrugada minha esposa
passou mal começou a sentir muita dor a
sua frio desmaiar e eu precisava
ajudá-la mas como eu poderia chamar uma
ambulância
se eu não escuto então eu mesmo coloquei
ela no carro e levei ao hospital
nós corremos muito chegamos no hospital
e ela precisava muito de atendimento
chegando a o hospital não tinha
sensibilidade comunicativa para os
surdos e eu fiquei com muita dúvida com
relação ao atendimento do médico porque
ele poderia me dedicar à minha esposa e
corretamente e nós poderíamos ter muitos
problemas com isso tudo por falta de
comunicação bem a minha história é cheia
de barreiras como essa eu vou contar
mais algumas pra vocês pra vocês
conhecerem um pouco da minha história
houve uma época que eu pegava mais o
transporte público porque eu as pessoas
com deficiência têm direito ao passe
livre nos transportes públicos
um dia eu estava muito cansado entrei
dentro do ônibus e tinha um lugar vazio
na frente e eu fiquei consome dormir
durante a viagem chegou uma pessoa com
um óculos escuro e sem bengala e ficou
parado do meu lado no ônibus e começou a
pedir licença e o pt precisa sentar e eu
dormindo e sem escutar o cego então não
percebeu que eu era surdo e imaginou que
tinha uma pessoa sem educação sentado
ele começou a me cutucar eu acordei mas
eu não percebi que era um cego porque
ele não estava de bem ela então uma
outra pessoa ou 20 que estava ali
começou a perceber a falta de respeito
começou a me xingar e começou uma briga
dentro do ônibus as pessoas foram
ficando nervosa e um rapaz me puxou pela
camisa e me levantou e eu levei muito
susto eu quase deu um murro na cara dele
porque eu não estava entendendo a
situação
aí quando eles perceberam que eu era
surdo
todo mundo levou um susto
eles ficaram todos envergonhados e sem
saber como fazer aí uma pessoa disse que
eu era surdo então eu cedi o lugar é
claro para o cego mas ficou aquela
situação devido à falta de comunicação
quando eu era criança eu tinha mais ou
menos dez anos de idade e o meu pai saiu
comigo pra comprar um picolé
quando eu peguei e picolé fiquei muito
feliz
era uma coisa que eu gostava muito e
quando eu vi tinha um amigo meu do outro
lado da rua na hora eu quis contar pra
ele que eu tinha ganhado picolé eu sair
então desesperado correndo pela rua pra
contar para o meu colega
nesse momento envie um carro muito
apressado me viu através ano e buzinou
mas eu sou surda
então nesse momento aconteceu um
acidente é isso mesmo
a mulher disse que não tinha culpa por
eu ser surdo e não ter ouvido a buzina
abel mas eu sou surdo é na verdade ela
realmente não tem culpa por eu ser surdo
mas ela também deveria ter respeitado a
sinalização que mandava parar e não
apenas ter buzinado vendo a placa
escrito pare e ter esperado que eu
parasse a ouvir
é o eu quebrei nesse momento meu fêmur e
também quebrei meu aparelho auditivo
eu como eu como eu já contei pra vocês
mas ia ouvindo e nessa época eu falava
cantava e tudo mais minha mãe me ensinou
tudo isso mas com dois anos então eu
tive a meningite e acabei diminuindo a
minha fala e também parei de cantar eu
quero contar um pouquinho dessa
experiência pra vocês da minha
experiência com o pré vestibular
eu fui fazer a inscrição né pra poder
estudar no pré-vestibular e nessa época
já era obrigatório intérprete de libras
então nós fomos ao pré-vestibular e eles
não tinham intérprete de libras e não
queriam me aceitar
eu e minha mãe então entramos com um
processo na justiça contra eles e eles
tinham que pagar mil reais por dia de
multa caso o intérprete de libras não
estivesse ali
depois desse processo eles ficaram
loucos e começaram a procurar intérprete
de libras para colocar então nós ficamos
um pouco mais tranqüilos depois disso
porque eles iriam pagar 2 mil 3 mil
reais
imagina só imagina um mês sem intérprete
de libras
eles então tiveram que se apressar mesmo
para encontrar esse profissional e eu
consegui estudar
estudei conseguir passar em dois
vestibulares e acabei escolhendo a puc
para estudar a minha família é toda de
pessoas que ouvem e eu sou o único surdo
isso é uma coisa muito complicada para
os surdos porque há uma grande falta de
comunicação nesses casos
imagina só onde uma família onde todos
falam e você é o único que não escuta
com uma comunicação acontece eu agradeço
isso muito a deus porque durante a minha
escolarização entrou um aluno um outro
aluno surdo na minha sala ea família
dele também era surda então foi com a
família dele que eu aprendi libras
a minha família então foi me ensinando
português enquanto a família do meu
amigo me ensinava libras
e assim eu fui desenvolvendo eu tenho
muito a agradecer a puc também porque eu
escolhi estudar na puc por ter um núcleo
de acessibilidade inclusão e desde o
primeiro dia de aula eu já tinha o
intérprete me acompanhando
vocês precisam saber um pouco como que é
a dificuldade na vida dos surdos
muitas vezes nós escrevemos por exemplo
redações e a maioria dos ouvintes
acreditam que os nossos textos estão
super errados eles não concordam com a
gente quando na verdade portuguesa é a
nossa segunda língua e têm muitas
palavras que nós não conhecemos
além do que a ordem das frases alteram
muito também
então muitas vezes na família no banco
nas lojas é muito difícil é conseguir se
comunicar porque afinal de contas nós
somos surdos e nós temos nós nos
sentimos muito prejudicados em muitos
ambientes
foi através disso que eu percebi que
muitas empresas pagam um curso de libras
para os funcionários para eles
aprenderem libras se conseguir se
comunicar com os surdos mas os cursos
têm duração de duas semanas
imagina só uma pessoa que estuda uma
língua por exemplo inglês
ela vai ficar ali fazendo um esforço
para aprender o inglês depois para
escrever em inglês em duas semanas ela
só é proficiente inglês é impossível a
língua brasileira de sinais é a mesma
coisa
é impossível aprender em duas semanas
então por isso que a tecnologia pode
auxiliar muito os surdos na comunicação
eu então criei a sigma web para auxiliar
na comunicação das empresas com os
surdos
então os surdos conseguem chegar em
vários lugares da sociedade e através de
um celular um computador de um tablet é
possível ele entrar encontrar em contato
com o intérprete virtual e esse
intérprete de casa auxilia na
comunicação entre o surdo e ouvinte
muito fácil não
aqui tem um exemplo de um surdo no
hospital
então ele através do notebook chamou
intérprete e conseguiu se comunicar de
um surdo de uma surda chamando internet
através do celular para auxiliar na
comunicação no banco
aqui é uma outra surda dentro de uma
loja de uma ótica é também pediu o
auxílio de um intérprete
e aqui nós temos solares que é o nosso
produto principal dentro da sigla web
ele significa liberdade autonomia
dignidade e igualdade para todos os
surdos muito interessante não é
é muito importante saber dessa notícia
também no mundo
são 70 milhões de surdos e aqui no
brasil são 9,7 milhões de surdos
nós somos muito prejudicados pela falta
de acessibilidade é muito importante
também saber que os surdos se comunicam
através das mãos da expressão facial e
do corpo
eu gostaria de deixar uma mensagem para
vocês de superação
os surdos podem ter qualquer profissão
podem ser atores professores
eu por exemplo sou um empreendedor e
criador de um sistema
então nós somos iguais surdos e ouvintes
eu gostaria de pedir encarecidamente que
parem de nos chamar de surdos surdo mudo
afinal de contas nós somos capazes de
falar
os surdos também podem ser organizados e
falar muito obrigada foi um prazer
conversar hoje com vocês muito obrigado